في غياب طبعا وزير خارجيه المغرب الذي كان
منتظرا ولكنه لم يحضر هنا في في جزيره
جربه هو الوزراء الخارجيه ما الذي يفعلونه
يعدون تقريرهم لوزراء لرؤساء دول
والحكومات اي لاجتماع القمه يوم غد في
الواقع قمه الفرنكوفنيه هي على غرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي القاده هم الذين يقررون
ما الذي يقرروا قرروا اولا انا الامين
العامه للمنظمه الدوليه لويس مشيكي وبوه
التي هي روانديه لم يترشح اي احد امامها
وان
الترشح لهذا المنصب انت منذ السادس من
اكتوبر وبالتالي ستكون هي الوحيده المرشحه
الا في حاله ما طلب رئيس دوله او رئيس
حكومه بانه له مرشح هذا اولا ثانيا من
سينوب تونس
كرئيس القمه لان ارمينيا هي التي ستسلم
القمه الى تونس ثم تونس تتراس هذه القمه
لمده سنه سنتين وهاعطيك منذ الان ان
سويسرا هي التي ستنوب تونس في رئاسه هذه
القمهذا ما تقرره هو الاعداد
لما يعرب ببيان جربه ومن بين الاشياء التي
ستتقرر هو ضروره الحديثه على ضروره وقف
هذه الانقلابات الموجوده في القاره
الافريقيه محاوله ايضا بالورد كل القيم
التي تدافع عنها منظمه المنظمه الدوليه
بدءا بدوله القانون ضروره احترام حقوق
الانسان وايضا حريه الصحافه والتعبير
التوفيق ذكرتها في بدايه المداخله اا غياب
وزير خارجيه المغربي ناصر بوريطه هل ندرج
ذلك في اطار التوتر الذي الشهيده تونس
والمغرب مؤخرا بعد استقبال قيس سعيد بن
سعيد جبهه البوليساريو
يعني الجدول نرانا وزير خارجيه المغرب لم
يتقر بعد اذن ال ال العباره مفهومه اذا
التونسيون كانوا يعتقدون انه سيكون حاضر
هنا هو طرحت سؤال على كثيرين طبعا هو له
علاقه بما حصل بين تونس والمغرب لست ادري
لماذا غابه عاده ونحن غطينا اكثر من قمه
وعدتنا ناصر بوريتا يشارك في هذه القمم لم
نرى مشاركه للملك ولكن راينا مشاركه الملك
اكيد له علاقه بهذا الموضوع ولكن ليس
الوحيد الذي تغيب عن القمه العديد من
الرؤساء على غرار مثلا رئيس جمهوريه
الكونغو الديمقراطيه لن يكون حاضرا امامنا
رئيس الوزراء ولكن هناك مشاركه مميزه بما
اننا في الساعه المغاربيه من بين الرؤساء
طبعا الرئيس الموريتاني الذي سيكون حاضر
هنا هو الذي وصل طبعا الى الى جربه
الافتتاح سيكون غدا وبنتظار طبعا هذا
البيان بيان شربه الذي ينتظره كثير ولو
انه هناك من يعلق ويقول
نحن في مشهد سياسي يتماشى ويتعاقلم مع
مبادئ المنظمه الدوليه لفرانكفورنيا وحتى
الامينه العامه لمنظمه الدوليه
لفرانكفورنيا عندما طرح عليها سؤال في
فرانس فانت كات هذا الصباح ترددت نوعا ما
في الرد هي تتمنى ان تجري الامور في ظروف
هادئه جدا على غرار ما يجري في جريس لان
كل الوفود على على الدرايه بمجريبيس اوضا
حصل ايضا في مدينه صفاقس ولكن هناك الان
توجه بالقول هناك قراءات متنوعه لمفهوم
الديمقراطيه وحريه التعبير وحريه الصحافه
في اكثر من بلد